oubliée la veine de roberto malone les
yeux de biche de tabatha cash ou les
performances de clara morgane aux
oubliettes aussi brigitte lahaie richard
allan les précurseurs du x français
tendance années 80 ici sur le salon de
l'érotisme ce sont les 10 k line ou
analystes qui font le show chaud mais ne
nous y trompons pas eropolis ce sont
d'abord des stands commerciaux où l'on
trouve d'abord de la lingerie mais aussi
des dilatateur veineux des godemichés
plus ou moins sophistiquées sans oublier
les vagins factice si bien que les
visiteurs une fois acquitté leur ticket
d'entrée deviennent des consommateurs
par curiosité sa première fois que j'ai
ici envie découvrir
pour le moment on a regardé puis aussi
quelque chose nous intéresse comprend
pas il y a donc les néophytes et les
initiés libérer pour certains libertin
facile d'engager la conversation moins
facile de faire une interview face
caméra pour expliquer les motivations
avec toujours le même argument la maison
de travail le travail la personne de la
famille exactement parce que voilà c'est
quand même le salon de l'érotisme il ya
des choses à caractère sexuel donc j'ai
pas non seulement vivre mes paroles boys
and girls s'acheter un nouveau chouchou
la lingerie coquine ça reste quand même
assez privé même si voilà les gens qui
viennent ici viennent pour ça enfin il y
a ceux plus rares qui considère la
société coincée hypocrite et voit le
sexe comme un jeu contact prend et puis
à l'ambiance c'est un milieu à part
c'est un monde différent
voilà et c'est ce que j'aime le plus
c'est
je suis dans mon univers quand j'y suis
je suis dans mon univers preuve terreau
police était dulko ray au fil des années
pour s'ouvrir à tous et à toutes
le salon n'est plus réservé aux seuls
majeur il est désormais autorisée aux
plus de 16 ans